seed thieves had a notoriously choppy
launch I'll be the first to admit it
I played for a few weeks back then and
quickly lost interest it was fun to set
sail with some friends but there just
wasn't enough to do after two years of
continuous work from the developers are
rare there's finally treasure here worth
digging for here's a scenario it's 3:00
a.m. your two-person sloop is anchored
at an outpost while you sell off the
loot from a 5-hour voyage before you
start did you raise the gold hoarders
emissary flag and throughout the night
you work to rank it up to level five now
every chest trinket and gem you sell is
worth two and a half times its normal
value but there's a catch sailing with
an emissary flag puts a giant red X on
your back another crew sinks your ship
and steals your flag they can sell it
for a high price and pirates who raise
the new Reapers bones faction flag can
even see you on their ships map if they
reach level 5 themselves in an instant
the worst thing imaginable happens and
your triumphant turnin becomes a fight
for your life another players sleep
rounds the corner behind your boat
adrenalin washes through your body like
an icy tidal wave but you saw them
coming way too late an enemy player has
already boarded your ship with an
explosive stronghold keg they set it off
as you hurl yourself from the deck
there's almost no way to recover from
this your entire boat is on fire the
hull is punched through with holes your
mast is down your steering wheel is
broken the capstan that raises your
anchor is half broken and the Cannonball
is being shot from the other boat are
knocking you around so badly that it's
hard to think
but somehow you're still alive you and
your crew mate repair the mast raise the
anchor put out the fires and lower the
sails all while bailing water
hammering planks over the gouges in the
hull and using your trusty blunderbuss
to fend off the other crews continued
attempts to board by this time your
hands are violently shaking you sail off
and do the only thing you can with the
pursuing ship directly behind you set
your boat on a clear heading jump off
the back and grab their ladders kill
them both and while they're waiting to
respawn you steer their boat onto some
rocks destroy their mast lower their
anchor and throw enough fire bombs to
light the whole thing up you catch a
mermaid back to your boat you did it you
lost them the hall is yours and once the
adrenaline dissipates from your system
you're going to sleep silently granted
hours later they need intended and with
vivid dreams of burning ships on a
colorful sea but still those kinds of
interactions with other players have
been seeing thieves main draw since the
game launched in 2018 but so many of the
particulars of that tense encounter I
just described were only possible
because of the countless features tools
and systems of the developers at rare
have added the game in the two years
since its release most recently in the
massive April 2020 update called ships
of fortune the fire that can spread
across your boat is new as are the
ability to revive fallen teammates the
damage that can be caused to masts the
harpoons adorning every ship the
rowboats you can find around the world
adorable pets that cost real money but
are totally worth it a new area of the
map fishing and cooking systems throw
bow grenades new world encounters like
skeleton fleets tough challenges like
the fort of the Damned and other small
and large surprises waiting to be
discovered on every new voyage
[Music]
but it's the emissary flags that have
really propelled save these into new
waters by incentivizing players in
various subtle ways the emissary system
solved many of the problems that have
plagued this game for years the risk
reward equation is simple the longer you
sail as an emissary the higher your
multiplier when you finally sell you
prizes but the more attractive you are
is a target for other players looking to
secure a payout without doing the work
themselves it alleviates some of the
game's intense grind by making it easier
to earn money in rank of factions
speeding up the climb to coveted pirate
legend status it encourages players to
seek one another out rather than avoid
conflict the long flapping emissary
flags are highly visible and a
high-level emissary spied in the
distance is a tempting prize to chase on
the other hand the emissary system is
completely optional if you don't raise
an emissary flag you'll get a lower
payout when you sell treasure at the end
of your voyage but you're also more
likely to be left alone by other players
see if thieves always have the
foundation of something great even from
its bare-bones launch it was a blast to
set sail with friends there just wasn't
much else to do but rares gradually fix
that with consistent content drops that
have added everything from story
missions to a PvP arena mode if you
haven't played in a while you're going
to discover a ton of new things the next
time you set sail granted as the game's
scope has continuously increased rare
has clearly found it challenging to keep
up with balance issues and bugs that
have remained present for a long time
that journey I described at the
beginning only stretched out to five
grueling hours long because a server
merge triggered a bug as they usually do
it caused us to lose control of our ship
ultimately sinking it that reset our
emissary rank and we had to spend hours
climbing back up to rank 5 to get the
best payout for the loot that we'd
already worked to earn fact that we
managed to get away is the only thing
separating that story of triumph from an
infuriating nightmare that probably
would have made me take a break from the
game for a few days there are plenty of
balance problems as well like the fact
that the blunderbusses damage feels like
it has more to do with your network pain
in your aim and nothing is more
frustrating than losing hours worth of
work not because you were surprised or
outmaneuvered by another player or due
to any mistake on your part but because
the game decided to spawn a Kraken a
Megalodon and a skeleton ship
simultaneously your location sometimes
while you're also in a storm or with a
dead
volcano erupting nearby the more time
you invest in sea of thieves the more
those instances seem to stack up
creating a laundry list in your mind of
all the things rare has failed to
address our improve and so much of this
game is designed to keep you playing the
grind to hip higher legend and unlock
the coolest stuff is way too intense for
most players one problem that emerges
the higher levels is the fact that short
sessions become increasingly unrewarding
creating a need to play for long
stretches without breaks literally if
you don't have around four hours to
commit at a certain point it's barely
worth embarking at all to compound that
the game regularly goes offline for
maintenance and patch releases but the
only in-game notification about it
appears just 15 minutes before the
server's shutdown which is barely long
enough to race to the nearest outpost
interior stuffing if you miss the
official tweet or reddit post about it
you're out of luck and you're likely to
feel like you wasted a bunch of time
climbing emissary ranks or fighting a
lengthy sea battle when the shutdown
arrives unexpectedly several hours into
your session on the other hand no matter
how high you climb you'll never actually
unlock any goner ship or tool that's
technically better than what everybody
else already has every single unlockable
in the game remains purely cosmetic to
this day what's the harm of some true
stretch goals for the most dedicated
pirates many players will never reach
those heights but unlike when see if
thieves launched at this point there's
no shortage of other things to do
besides chase cosmetics there's one
other thing I feel I need to address
there's a subset of players who to this
day think the game needs PvE servers
where you can't be attacked by other
players but the danger of being dumped
stirred by any other crew at any other
time is this games beating heart no
matter how good you think you are the
possibility of crushing defeat is always
lurking just behind the next wave it
just wouldn't be sea of thieves without
that since the game's launch over two
years ago rare has worked continuously
to build on see if thieves strong
framework and the countless features and
systems they've added have all enhanced
that core undeniable truth they still
have work to do and for some players
that will never be enough but there are
open seas and clear skies ahead for the
current and future pirate legends out
there and even for the players who will
never reach that level but simply want
to make some of their own tall tales out
on the unforgiving waves see if these is
finally a voyage worth embarking on
[Music]
[Applause]